let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 a lot of people eager to get on today
let's start with our caller from the
8:06 area code who's calling today from
806 hello how's it going good who's this
i named la mark hey Lamont what's up hey
I just had a quick question it's a
little open-ended as you know there's a
lot of Democratic candidates in
particular mind which is supporting
Sanders talking about increasing minimum
wage yes now I know that he and many
others have been trying to do this since
the 90s etc I wanted to know even after
he leaves what we have is a major
problem systemic in my opinion which is
the cost of inflation or the rate of
inflation continues to change I know
that there's different things like the
fair labor standard act or different
acts that were made I just wanted to
hear your thoughts on do you believe
that whoever the candidate is whether
Bernie Elizabeth or whoever should set
up an agency or give more power to an
agency that's independent of Congress to
be able to naturally adjust the minimum
wage without having to go through
Congress where they gridlock a bunch of
foolishness et cetera yeah I mean so the
answer is yes the minimum wage should be
indexed to inflation inflation merely to
keep up with inflation the the more
complicated element of it is that cost
of living is arguably more difficult to
pin down the national inflation and that
because the minimum wage is very
regionalised what counts as a living
wage in some parts of the country is not
in other parts of the country so there
are some studies which suggests that you
should actually tie the minimum wage to
cost of living which of course is very
very different in different parts of the
country and even within states and that
that's where we should be looking and
both politically and logistically that's
much more difficult now let me say one
other thing Lamont we actually have it
pretty good in the United States as far
as inflation in my birth country of
Argentina the inflation is I mean it's
it's been cartoonish for 15 years it's
crazy what's going on there
in the US fortunately yes there's a
political obstacle to overcome in terms
of getting the minimum wage indexed to
inflation but at least our inflation is
very very low compared to what's going
on in countries like Argentina and it's
not nearly as big of a problem as it
could be thank you I really appreciate
your thoughts lovely so keep up the
great work all right thank you very much
appreciate hearing from you Lamont